today we go back to the Atlantic which
has recently become very fertile soil
for the daily cancellation last week we
had to cancel a woman who wrote an
article for the publication trying to
explain why nobody should care about a
woman's body count and today we have a
not entirely unrelated subject this time
written by a woman named Annie Lowry and
the headline poses a question which is
this is single Parenthood the problem
now if I were the author the text of the
article would be very short in fact it
would be one word and the answer would
be yes
single Parenthood is the problem or it
is at least a problem a very big one but
Lowry has more to say than that and not
everything she says is wrong she begins
quote the most heavily anticipated
economics book of the Year makes a
radical argument
having married parents is good for kids
I know I know it seems like a joke right
of course having to involve parents
living in a stable home together is good
for kids anyone who is considered having
children with a partner was ever a child
themselves must know that but for years
academic studying poverty mobility and
family structures have avoided that
self-evident Truth The Economist Melissa
Kearney writes in the two-parent
privilege release this week and while
the wonks avoided the topic the rise of
single-parent households in America
exacerbated inequality and contributed
to astonishingly High rates of child
poverty now this part is all true of
course but there's much more to say in
fact uh this is the whole story right
here that would at least make for a more
interesting article in the Atlantic I
would think
everyone knows it's better for kids to
be raised by two parents than by one
yeah that's how things are naturally set
up every child has two biological
parents no child has ever had one or
three only two
which which is a pretty good indication
that they are supposed to be raised by
two
and those two just to be clear are a man
and a woman
this is the most natural thing
or I should say it's nature in its
elevated civilized state
now in the animal kingdom in most cases
babies are conceived the father runs off
after copulation uh and uh the babies
are are born and they're raised only by
their mothers and and usually only for a
short time before they're out on their
own
so single Parenthood becoming more
common and accepted in human society is
a society is a sign that Society is
devolving
people are behaving more like cats and
crocodiles than human beings
single Parenthood is it's literally
animalistic it's it's what you find in
the animal kingdom
it's it's a it's a family Arrangement
that you can find in the forest or in
the jungle or out on the Serengeti
it's not meant for Human Society we are
not beasts we are people
and we're supposed to raise our children
both parents father and mother now
obviously we're speaking here on the
broad societal Level Society devolves
and it becomes more animalistic when it
accepts and promotes single Parenthood
as a positive good as equal to the
nuclear family or even better than it
now that isn't to say that
obviously every single parent themselves
has done something wrong necessarily if
a child is raised by one parent because
the other parent died for example then
that's a situation where you have no
choice but to make do and those parents
deserve a lot of credit and a lot of
respect
uh the same for a situation where a
child is raised by one parent because
the other abandoned the family
the one who is left is uh is now the one
who left the family and abandoned the
family is acting like an animal the one
who is left is doing the best they can
to compensate
the trouble is that many kids are being
raised in single-parent households
because both parents are irresponsible
and selfish or because the single parent
chose to break up the family for no good
reason this is why the universal
celebration of single moms as if they're
all victims put in a difficult spot
through no fault of their own has always
been horribly misguided
now some of them are victims who are put
in a difficult spot uh through no fault
of their own but certainly not all
probably not the majority
but as the author notes the so-called
experts the academics the economists the
uh the college professors the
politicians and so on have for many
years ignored or outright denied these
basic realities
it's just one of the one of the great
many basic realities that these people
have tried to cover up or distract us
from
they tie themselves into pretzels to try
and explain why it's good actually for
kids to have only one parent raising
them instead of two
they tried desperately to pretend that
all family arrangements are equally
valid equally good equally likely to
lead to well-adjusted children who can
Thrive as functional adults in society
on this topic as on so many other topics
the experts use their alleged expertise
to lead Society deeper into confusion
and self-destruction and now they have
the gall to complain that people no
longer trust the expert class
well how can we trust them
you know I mean they've only been
horrendously wrong about everything my
entire life
they've only tried to tear human
civilization apart at the seams
other than that they've earned our trust
and we could spend longer analyzing all
this but the author moves on and we get
to this part well but it is worth asking
what good comes of pointing out that
many people could use a cohabitating
partner and that many kids could use a
second involved parent
Kearney has written an important careful
Book on a topic that is an elephant in
the room as she puts it still I'm not
sure anyone has any idea what to do with
the elephant kearney's on research and
the research of other Scholars convinced
her that the rise of single Parenthood
wasn't important and overlooked social
phenomenon a key to understanding the
country's low rates of mobility and high
rates of poverty
well I have to say
um no it was not overlooked okay the
problem of a single Parenthood was not
overlooked
it was overlooked by the Atlantic
perhaps and by the rest of the mass
media and by those experts we talked
about a moment ago but some people the
social conservatives specifically we've
been talking about this and warning
about it for decades
okay it wasn't overlooked by us
it's just that we have been shouted down
and ignored for decades
now the people who ignored us are slowly
but surely coming around to the
realization that we were right about
this like we are right about literally
everything
okay the social conservatives have been
right about every
cultural issue
since forever we've been right about
everything we are always right always
it's just that you know and eventually
on every topic eventually the experts
come around and they say you know uh I
think maybe it should be this way
instead
but they won't acknowledge that we were
right
they always come around to the
realization that we were right but they
never say you were right
because they want to continue to
demonize the very people who arrived at
the conclusions
50 years ago that they're just arriving
at now
in any case the article continues laying
out more of the economic and social
problems that come with single
Parenthood and most of what it says
again is correct but then we get to the
final paragraph which says this
quote the real elephant in the room I
think is that United States doesn't want
to contemplate let alone create a policy
infrastructure that supports single
Parenthood it doesn't want to make sure
that kids Thrive with a single earner in
the home it won't do this even though it
seems obvious that a large share of
children are going to grow up with one
parent going forward and even though we
aren't realistically going to increase
the marriage rate among lower lower
income Americans we don't want to build
a society where children are seen as a
collective gift and a collective
responsibility it's not single
Parenthood that's failing these kids we
all are
uh no it's single Parenthood that's
failing them um we aren't failing the
kids okay what's this we stuff speak for
yourself
I can speak for myself at least because
we includes me and uh I'm not failing
them if there's a child in a single
parent home across the street because
the mom had sex with some random guy
outside of marriage and they both had no
interest in marrying in order to create
a stable home for that child then
uh that child has been failed but not by
me
if he's in a single parent home because
the mom got bored with her marriage and
decided to rip the family apart so that
she could go off and find herself or
whatever then again
the child has been failed but not by me
and if he's in a single parent home
because the dad is a deadbeat who ran
out on the family then once again that
child has been failed but not by me
and not by you and not by us and not by
we
the child's mother failed him or his
father failed him or in most cases they
both failed him
100 of the failure comes from some
combination of the mom and the dad for
most homeowners window replacement isn't
something they've done before and for
many it isn't something they want to do
but rather something they have to do if
you've put off replacing windows in your
home because it's too expensive I have
great news you can now get a free
in-home window consultation and a free
price quote from the Renewal by Anderson
Renewal by Anderson signature service is
committed to giving you the best
customer experience possible through the
perfect combination of the best people
in the industry a superior process and
an exclusive product right now Renewal
by Anderson is offering a free in-home
or virtual consultation on durable
quality affordable windows or patio
doors for zero dollars down zero
payments and zero interest for a year
tax Walsh to 200 300 for your free
consultation to save 375 off every
window and 750 off every door these
savings won't last long so be sure to
check it out by texting Walsh to 200 300
that's Walsh to 200 300 texting privacy
policy in terms conditions supposed to
textplan.us texting enrolls for
recurring automated text marketing
messages message and data rates apply I
reply stop topped out go to
windowappointmentnow.com for full offer
details now
as always the left wants to remove
personal responsibility from this
conversation and from every conversation
but you can't
because ultimately there is no solution
to the single parent problem
outside of adults making better choices
if they will not make better choices
then nothing will get better that's the
reality
all we can do if if the rate and volume
of bad choices doesn't change then all
we can do is try out try our best to to
deal with the mess that these selfish
jerks are creating
and some of that will involve policy
changes yes but the policies should not
be tailored to support single Parenthood
rather the policy should encourage and
promote marriage and two-parent
households
okay we've done more than enough to
support single paranoid too much in fact
we need to support two parent households
in order to eventually have fewer of the
kinds of households that are creating
all of these problems
are children a collective gift sure
um are they a collective responsibility
I mean yeah in a broad sense
but there is a hierarchy of
responsibility for each individual
and your responsibility starts closest
to you and it branches out from there
this means the the first responsibility
you have is to your own family your own
children
you cannot go out and and be Reckless
and irresponsible and then expect
Society to take care of you and your
kids because Society is comprised of
individuals and each individual has a
list of priorities
and neither you or your children will
ever be at the top of it
that's not because they're selfish it's
because they have their priorities
straight
and they have to take care of their own
Families First that's how it's set up
so it's up to you first and foremost to
make sure that your children have what
they need and what they need first and
foremost is a mom and a dad in the home
Society can't provide that and the
government can't provide it
only you can
and that has to be the first step
Annie Lowry of the Atlantic seems to get
close to this realization but she
doesn't make it all the way because
these people never do
and for that reason she is today
canceled thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt Walsh show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcasts